imsamah the secret ruler of the world
government probably has the most
mind-boggling power in all of one piece
if you thought the nico fruit was
overpowered then emo is about to be
straight up broken with one of the
strongest devil fruit powers imaginable
i mean if this is correct then emo is
clearly one piece final boss material
okay so the king of the pirates is the
person with the most freedom on the sea
but little does luffy know little does
the world know that there is a true king
in the one piece world and that no one
is free if anyone is to claim the one
piece it's not the rival members of the
worst generation that they have to worry
about nor the fearsome yonko not even
the almighty cross guild is the biggest
threat on the grand line right now
despite having the greatest swordsman in
the world and the greatest clown in the
world among their numbers now the
faction that has the most to lose from
the one piece being discovered is the
world's government but future fleet
admiral sakazuki didn't think twice
about condemning an entire island to a
fiery death if it meant restricting the
knowledge of the ponoglyphs the objects
that reveal the true history and lead to
the ultimate treasure i mean they'd even
imprison one of their own cp9 agents
who's who for losing the nika fruit
which is somehow connected to the legacy
of joy boyd the one who ultimately
created the one piece it's obvious that
the world government will do anything to
stop this treasure from being revealed
and at the top of the world government
at the top of the whole world is not a
pirate king that seat has long said
vacant ever since roger's execution the
person with the most power and i guess
freedom in the one-piece world even if
most of the people don't know about it
is the mysterious insama and chances are
that this mysterious entity will pull
out all the stops in order to prevent
any pirates from claiming the one piece
and learning the true history there are
a lot of candidates for who will be
luffy's final opponent could it be kainu
or blackbeard or the infamous buggy the
clown we actually made a whole video
about just that that you can check out
later only time will tell really who
luffy's final matchup will be but but
imzama is one of the prime candidates
here without any doubts i mean the world
government and in extension the marines
have been the story's leading
overarching antagonist ever since the
earliest chapters in the east blue even
if the final opponent ends up being the
world government and not another pirate
crew like blackbeard or shanks the most
likely big bad guy could be and should
be even though luffy has a personal
grudge against the kainu im sama is the
ultimate leader of the world government
and a kainu and if luffy represents this
whole new dawn of the world if he beats
the drums of liberation and brings
freedom to the world then he may
represent the opposite the highest
authority in the world putting people
across the seas in chains both literally
and metaphorically i guess but if eem is
a fighter worthy of occupying the spot
of luffy's final opponent then they need
to give us one hell of a fight and he
needs a power set that contends with the
wild abilities of the sun god's nike
fruit one of the prevailing theories of
nico's fruit is that they have the most
overpowered possible fruit the water
water fruit or sea sea fruit or ocean
ocean or the fruit of some unnamed sea
god whatever you want to call it it's
the wettest fruit around pure water as
opposed to muddy water like caribou
swamp or cold water like busan's ice
powers i guess technically cousin is
just cold or whatever what matters is
that devil fruit users all lose the
ability to swim the sea drains them of
their abilities and even the ability to
move while being submerged so someone
with a water water fruit would be a
natural counter not only to something
like the miramira no me like luffy was
with anna's lightning fruit but we're
talking about a heart counter to every
single devil fruit if we think that the
nika fruit seems opie with all its
abilities seemingly breaking reality and
applying cartoon logic to luffy
stretching and shape shifting then get
ready to a whole lot op your pier when
im summa simply turns off all devil
fruit abilities with just a nice big
soak besides the idea that a water fruit
would of course just be absurdly broken
it would make a lot of sense for imsama
to have the japanese word umi means sea
or ocean umi backward spelt is emu
coincidence well probably not given how
much oda loves his wordplay it's just
too on the nose not to have any meaning
at all and i mean thematically emo
having a sea fruit makes sense as well
they're the being with the most power on
the seas the dangerous oceans of the one
piece world are what keep people
separated isolated from each other on
their individual small islands really
only by gathering a capable crew with a
navigator and so on and so forth by
braving the treacherous tights and
turbulence weather of the grand line can
members of different countries even
connect politically and economically in
the first place and so this separation
makes it of course all the lot easier
for the world government to exert
control over the seas especially giving
their monopoly on kailseki seastone that
allows their ships to move safely
through the combat bypassing its deadly
sea kings if im sama controls the oceans
in a figurative sense maybe their fruit
allows them to control the oceans in a
much more literal sense however this is
of course not the only power that would
make sense for this all-powerful figure
of the one piece worlds if emu is umi
backwards maybe they're not the ocean at
all maybe they're the opposite of the
ocean the classic oda you know spin
arounds and a lot of the time when we're
thinking about elemental powers we think
of water and fire being opposites but in
the context of one piece i don't think
that fire really makes sense as the
opposite of the ocean i would actually
go much more pokemon emerald with this
cause in one piece you're either at sea
or you're on lance we've seen pika stone
fruit and crocodile sand fruit and we've
even had miss merry christmases
tunneling mole fruit but we've yet to
see a proper earth earth fruit in the
series the closest maybe might be the
revolutionary commander morley's
oshioshinomi which allows her to push
the ground and mold it as is for clay
however this fruit is a paramecia we're
still missing an earth logia in a club
that includes other elements like fire
ice and so on forest speaking of morley
though it's really interesting because
did you know that this revolutionary has
a bounty of almost 300 million berries
impressive and befitting of the world's
most wanted people in the world it's far
more than the slithering slime man
trebles 99 million barry bounty and with
your help we could also overtake treble
and raise our own bouncy by hitting that
subscribe button and raising my bounty
by 100 berries too now the earth fruit
of course doesn't feel as overpowered as
something like a sea fruit but it also
feels a lot more likely to exist in the
first place if devil fruit users are
cursed by the sea and the sea is their
ultimate weakness it might not make much
sense for there to be a seafood after
all and we really can't discard earth as
one of the four classic elements it
would definitely still pack quite a
punch as a devil fruit and having the
earth fruit would make a lot of thematic
sense for emu as well pirates like luffy
setting out to sea is representative of
finding freedom and adventure it's the
opposite of being trapped on land like
luffy was for so long when he was too
young still to set sail with ace or
shanks and so if the open sea gives
pirates freedom then the earth or the
land represents the opposites i mean
where else but the land do the straw
hats find corrupt kingdoms and
monarchies like that of walpole and
pirates like arlong crocodile and
doflamingo gave up adventuring on sea
well they also turned to dominating
others on islands on lands and emo
having the earth fruit would also solve
one of the biggest mysteries in one
piece who created the red line and how
back when luffy's fruit was still
thought to be just a rubber fruit he
showed us how creative strong and
willful fruit users can turn even an
average fruit into a force to be really
reckoned with now the earth fruit might
not seem overpowered compared to other
logia fruits at first glance but imagine
if emu is powerful enough to create a
whole continent if emo was alive during
the void century which is very likely
perhaps they're the reason that there
are no continents anymore save the red
line using an earth earth fruit imsamah
would have reshaped the world to their
liking land masses could have been sunk
leaving the human population desperate
and scattered all across distant islands
the red line could have been erected to
serve as a boundary to border seas from
each other and restrict travel between
parts of the globe eem's home itself
marijuana even sits atop this mighty
landmass and if this really is eem's
power then luffy will need a fruit as
powerful as the mika fruit i mean to
even stand a chance in the first place
but and i know you've been waiting for
this water and earth aren't the only
option for emo's potential power either
there could be a to be determined
mythical zone to rival the nika fruit
maybe a sea god fruit or while we
speculated in a previous video that you
can watch here that blackbeard possesses
a moon god fruit maybe eemsama is the
real moon god to luffy sun god instead
if oda does have eem as the final
villain instead of blackbeard that could
be very fitting too and after seeing
shanks's incredible feat of conquerors
haki in chapter 1055
we have to really wonder if eem even
needs a devil fruit at all in the first
place perhaps just like shanks im sama
is just a purely overpowered hockey user
however one has to really wonder in that
case how strong is the conqueror's haki
of someone who has literally conquered
the entire globe shanks's haki stopped
aramaki in his tracks from miles off
away the coast of wano so could meem's
haki have even further reached than just
that then there's also the matter of the
saber that eem carries so far we've only
seen them use it to tear bounty posters
like a little child in order to let the
gorosei know which light needs to be
extinguished we do have to wonder though
if maybe that's not all that that sword
is good for i mean luffy is particularly
susceptible to cutting slashing and
stabbing attacks but this would be a
strange route for oda to go down to
either mihawk isn't actually the
strongest swordsman in the world and
it's team instead or zorro would end up
with a more powerful opponent than luffy
in the final war which i do know there
are some people out there who would
probably be okay with that but then of
course there is also a somewhat
anti-climactic option emo might just not
be a fighter in the first place it
wouldn't be the first time that a major
antagonist wasn't a combatant in water 7
and its lobby one of the other notable
times the straw hats went up against the
world government directly the leader of
cp9 and arguably the central villain was
spanden spandom despite his special
sword funk freed was not a fighter as he
proved to us a lot of times this
incompetent sniveling and utterly
punchable cypherpol operative relied on
the muscle of zp9 and robluchi and lucci
ended up becoming luffy's primarily
fighting opponent for that arc so it
could be that imsamad like most
celestial dragons simply relies on the
military might of the marines to carry
out their will and for their protection
it could be that the gorosei serve as
eem's elite guard though it isn't yet
quite confirmed whether they're fighters
either i mean you and me just really
really really hope that we will see
gandhi break out that sword at some
point and so while i personally like to
believe that they must have some sort of
power it's still unclear what emu's role
in the story will actually be but after
the introduction at the reverie it's
very clear that they will play a pivotal
maybe the central role in the final saga
we still need to know what the great
cleansing is all about and to learn how
the world government plans to carry it
all out maybe the marine secret weapon
the ssg the special science group will
play some part in it but with so little
one piece left here's to hoping that oda
can pack in as many wild fights and
earth-shattering revelations as possible
and if you track all the people that
luffy still has to punch before the end
of the story and why well you should
really watch this video right here next